And now welcome
Aswin! How are you doing? Hi, Daniel.
I'm good. Hanging out,
looking forward. Can you hear me
properly? Yeah, sounds good. And yes,
looking forward to your workshop on
sophisticated inference in pymdp. So it
can be up to 90 minutes or it's totally
okay if it's less and we can take a
short break, but please take it away
and just let me know however I can help.
Great. Thank you so much. Maybe I'll
share my screen and start. So,
regarding the structure of what we are
doing here, I'm assuming that people who
see this later might want to try it
hands on along with the tutorial or
something. So that's the structure I
kept in mind. And so I'll go slow.
Please bear with me. So welcome all of
you to this session on sophisticated
inference in pymdp. So here we are going
to attempt to model some sophisticated
inference simulations, especially the
one in the original paper using the
pymdp module and how it is not part of
pymdp right now. But we are on the
process of adding sophisticated
inference to the pymtp module. And I'm
going to mainly talk about the code that
I have developed to kind of add that
functionality. Right. So I'm Ashwin
Paul. I am finally a PhD candidate at
Monash University. And mostly I work
with active inference models and try to
understand how to use them as an
explainable model to basically
understand emergence of intelligent
behavior. Right, so let's dive into the
material right away.
So to give an intro of free energy
principle, I'm sure all of you right now
have an understanding of what it is.
But the central idea is that an agent is
always trying to minimize the entropy
of its observations, right? So if an
observation is having really low
probability in your mind and that
happens, then you are probably surprised
and vice versa, right? And the entropy
here is defined as the information
theoretic entropy, where if you have a
low probability, then automatically this
is a high surprise or a high entropic
observation. And as we all know, active
inference also gives us a methodology to
define what we call an agent environment
loop. And this lets us define what is
the agent that we are looking at and
what is the behavior of the agent given
the environment around it and so on.
Right? So you're also familiar with the
idea of Marco Blanket. And this is
important because we always have to
remember, I mean, have to remember the
difference between the generative
process and the generative model, which
is quite a famous point of
confusion in active inference literature
and for the people who try to understand
it in the beginning. Right? So the
central question is that how does an
agent minimize entropy? Because how
does an agent know which observation is
low or high probabilistic? Right? So
that is by maintaining a generative
model. And the generative model will
tell you which is a high probabilistic
observation and which is a low
probabilistic observation. So the idea
is that all the agent has access to is
an observation that is coming from a
generative process which the agent
cannot directly observe. And an
intelligent agent will try to build up a
generative model in its mind, which is a
model of the hidden states and the
observation it has access to. And it can
hope to kind of compute probabilities
using this generative model, right? But
there is a problem that in general it is
an intractable problem to kind of
marginalize the probability of
observations from the generative model.
And that is why we have to define an
upper bound on the surprise that the
agent is trying to minimize. And there
comes the idea of free energy, right?
So this upper bound the agent is
supposedly minimizing is the free
energy. And that's why it is the free
energy principle. And here we have a new
term called capital QS, which can be
interpreted as the belief that the agent
is maintaining about the hidden state in
its generative model. And this quantity
is the free energy. And traditionally we
see this variational free energy being
interpreted as in mostly the
machine learning way where it is a
balance between complexity and accuracy
of the model. So when minimizing the
free energy, the agent is trying to come
up with a single model but at the same
time an accurate model because here it's
a minus sign with accuracy, right? It
can also be interpreted in the physics
way where the agent is always trying to
minimize the energy of the model but at
the same time maximizing the entropy of
the model which goes in conjunction with
the maximum entropy principle and so on
from the classic literature. So, given
that this idea of a generative model is
so important in a software point of
view, that's the first thing that you
might want to do, right, to define a
generative model for the agent which is
informed or not informed depending upon
the experiment that you're trying to
model. So in classical active inference,
usually decision making is defined in
terms of policies. So, for example, if
you are an agent in this environment so
in the Mario game, Mario is the agent
and everything else is the environment.
And Mario has three available
actions run, jump or stay in
this environment. And the classic
definition of policy is that it is a
sequence of actions in time. So if you
have a time horizon of capital T, then a
policy is nothing but a series of
actions you might take. So run, run,
jump and so on in time. So this is the
SuperScript is the action. So here it is
jump, run and so on. And the subscript
is the time. And then what you
can have is a policy space, which is a
collection of many such policies,
small pi. And what you essentially do to
take decisions in active inference is
compute, not optimize. Compute the
expected free energy of every policy in
your policy space. And basically, that
can be interpreted as a balance between
risk and ambiguity.
So when you compute this expected free
energy, what you're trying to do is
minimizing the risk. That is,
how different is your belief about the
observation from your prior preferences?
Capital C. So this is also part of the
generative model when you're trying to
model control and at the same time you
are trying to minimize the ambiguity
when you are choosing a policy that has
the minimum expected free energy,
right? But this formulation has a
problem that a policy space quickly
becomes intractable, that there can be
an enormous number of small pies or
policies in your policy space and
sitting and computing the expected free
energy for all such policies even for a
small time horizon, is not possible.
But this is the classical structure
that has been implemented in Pymdp
nonetheless, where we have different
modules in Pymdp that is meant to be
implementing different aspects of
behavior. So for example, for inference
or perception we have belief
propagation, fixed point iteration,
marginal message passing and all that
implemented in the inference module. In
the control module we have different
methods to evaluate expected free energy
for policies, one depending upon the
expected utility, the other one
depending upon the classic method
that I just explained. Then we have
module for learning. So we learn the
parameters in the form DP like capital
A, capital B, so likelihood transition
dynamics and so on. And then we have
algorithms for implementing all this in
the algorithms module. And then the most
powerful thing in Pymdp right now is the
agent class where it is easy for you to
kind of define the agent environment
loop and we are trying
to build up. So today I'm going to talk
about an agent class that implements
sophisticated inference rather than the
classical active inference that we just
saw. So, as I mentioned,
how many valid policies can be defined,
say for a time horizon of 15 in
classical active inference? Right? So
the first policy of course, is a series
of first action that is jumped, then you
can have the last action changed and you
already can see that there can be n
number of combinations. And for this
simple case, the policy space is as big
as ten to the power 13. And in a
stochastic problem setting there is no
way to kind of come up with a small
subset of this policy space so that you
can tackle this problem of computational
complexity. And yeah, as I mentioned,
in a stochastic problem setting it is an
intractable size policy space. There
comes the idea of sophisticated
inference where we are thinking about
taking decisions in a different way,
right? So rather than thinking about
sequence of actions in time, we can
directly think of what to do when we see
something depending upon our beliefs
about the current state and beliefs
about the future, right? So if I see
myself in a current situation, what
should I do? And that's more like a
straightforward thinking of how to take
actions. And here the expected free
energy. The structure of the expected
free energy is the same but we are not
evaluating expected free energy of
policies, but expected free energy of
observation action combinations. So if I
see something and if I do this, what's
the expected free energy? And that's
what I'm trying to minimize. That's what
I'm trying to optimize
in this setting, right? So here again,
we have the risk term where we are
trying to minimize the deviation between
the belief and the prior preferences.
We also have the ambiguity term and this
together makes up the expected free
energy of this time point at time T.
But we also have an expectation about
what's the expected free energy in the
next time step. And to evaluate the
expected free energy of next time step,
you will have to again compute this
equation with OT plus two. And for that
equation with OT plus three and so on.
And this automatically becomes a tree
search because of the recursive way this
equation is defined and it comes with
its own problems, but there are clever
ways to get around them and we are going
to discuss that in the code today. So,
given the structure of sophisticated
inference here, as I mentioned, the
research replace the policy space that
we saw for the traditional active
inference we are used to. So in this
workshop, what I am focusing on is how
to kind of define a generative model
and given an environment. So for
example, this is the grid that is
simulated in the original paper and we
are going to talk about how to build up
a generative model for this grid that
can be used in the sophisticated
inference in the PMDP module.
So basically, what I'm trying to talk
about is that the environment will have
a step function that takes an action
from the agent in Pymdp, and the agent
will get an observation out of that
action and we'll talk about this
particular function, agent step and
agent steps. Step will take up an
observation and try to come up with an
action for the next time. Step right.
And this creates a loop and cleverly
designing this loop will let you see
emergence of purposeful behavior in the
sophisticated inference setting. So for
example, in this particular grid with
sufficient planning horizon, you will be
able to see that the agent is capable of
navigating in this grid and so on. So
this is the example that I'm going to
focus on in this talk today.
Excuse me,
I want to right away jump in to the
code. So we have the
Pymdp home, which I'm
hoping you are familiar with. So we have
this GitHub repository where we have the
pymdp module and inside pymdp module
we have several parts for it.
So here we have the agent in the
original Pymdp module that implements
the so called classical active
inference. We have several environments
and we have help of functions like
learning inference, maths and so on. So
this is the module of Pimedp. But in the
parent folder we also have examples
where there is tutorials about how
to use the agent class, how to kind of
deal with the environments and so on.
So if you look at the pull requests so
we are right now trying to merge
sophisticated inference into the
original Pymdp module. And today I'm
going to talk about the code in this
pull request. So if you want to try this
hands on, you might want to go to this
page where this pull request is there
and it has the same structure of Pymdp.
It's basically designed using Pymdp.
And here what we have additionally is an
agent si which is a sophisticated
inference agent which does everything
and also planning and decision making in
the sophisticated inference way. And in
the parent folder there is also an
example folder for sophisticated
inference demo. And what I am going to
do today is to walk you through this
tutorial of sophisticated inference.
And on the way, I'm going to discuss and
at points where I reference the
helper codes, I'm going to go to that
code and try to explain what's actually
happening and how we complete that agent
environment loop where we can see that
purposeful behavior. Right?
Yeah. So that's the Pymdp home. Then I
also talked about the pull request. So
let's right away go into the jupyter
notebook. So this is my local copy of
this repository, so it's easier for me
to run it and show it in my personal
computer. So this is the parent folder
with Pymdp and examples and inside
examples I have a demo folder for
sophisticated inference and this is the
notebook I'm talking about. Right? So
here in this example, what we are trying
to do is deal with this particular grid
world task from the original
sophisticated inference paper and make
this agent or enable this agent to
navigate to this red dot, which is
supposedly the goal state in this
particular task given a prior preference
like this, right? So this prior
preference is quite informative in the
sense that we right away can see that
this is the most preferred state, the
white color and the surrounding states
are kind of less preferred, but more
preferred than the faraway ones. Right?
So this is the grid world task that we
are trying to use. So the first cell is
importing all the necessary libraries
and some useful libraries like NumPy and
Matplotlib. And the most important one
is Pymdp. So I'm actually now calling
the local copy of my Pymdp with the
sophisticated inference implementation,
not the original one, which is not
merged yet. And the first thing I want
to talk about is the environment itself,
right? So the environment step part
where if I get some action, how does the
environment work? And for that, inside
this folder I have a file which is Grid
environment Si PY and
this is basically an environment class.
So don't worry about how this
environment is actually implemented.
The only thing to worry about is this
function that we are going to use which
is environment step. So this function
will take an action into it and
depending upon the current state of the
environment, it will calculate what is
the most probable next state given this
action from the agent. So that's the
idea. And then it will also calculate a
reward of some negligible negative value
if it is not the Gold State, and if it
is the Gold State, it will give a reward
of ten. And that's how the environment
is. Designed and it will update the
current state to the new state. And
basically what it will return is a new
state, depending upon your action, the
reward for that action and whether it is
an end of the episode and so on. So this
implementation is the standard OpenAI
environment implementation and this is
the environment step function, right?
So in this grid, for example,
if I am right now in this state and if I
take an action up, so I have four
available actions north, South, east and
west. So if I go on north, then the
environment step will make sure that I
am in the state that is above the state.
And if I go east or west, then I'll stay
here. Or south. I'll stay here. So
that's the idea. And there is an episode
length limit that is eight here, that
means that I am restricting the length
of every episode to be eight, which is
the ideal length of reaching this goal
state just to avoid confusion. So in
this environment, after eight actions,
the environment will terminate. And if
you have to kind of reach this goal
state in the optimal time point so
that's the idea how the environment is
implemented. Okay,
I hope that is clear. And there are many
helpful functions in this environment,
like rendering
the environment, rendering a prior
preference matrix in this environment.
So if you design a prior preference,
this environment can show that in a
pictorial way how your prior preference
is that you will see in the notebook
below. So now it's time that we define
a generative model for the sophisticated
inference agent, right? Before that,
let's define the structure of the
generative model that we want the agent
to have in its mind, which is tailor
made for this particular environment,
right? So here in this particular grid
world task, we have 25 valid states
starting from this state. All this black
states in this path are valid states.
So there are 25 valid states. Then there
are four available actions for the
agent, north, Southeast and west. So
this is part of our generative model.
This is also in alignment with
the reality of the grid. But this is
about what the agent has in its mind,
right? And then the observation is just
the state space.
The problem is fully observable, so
there is no ambiguity there. Then we
define basically the number of states.
Then we define basically the number of
states, which is a list of your state
space, number of factors, which is now
one because you only have one hidden
state factor here. Then number of
controls, which is going to be four.
That's four available actions and your
observation space like that. So this is
the structure of your generative model.
And let's look at the structure of the
parameters now inside a POMDP. So the
first one is the likelihood function
which is often denoted by capital A.
And here it is a function of how many
observational modalities I have and how
many state modalities I have. Right? If
I run this cell, yeah, I have to run the
parent cell to make sure everything
works. So I have rendered the
environment the structure of the
generative model. And here I have the
capital A matrix which has a structure
25 25. That means that I have 25 states
and 25 observations. And here, because
it's fully observable, I am initializing
it as an identity matrix of size 25.
So that's my likelihood matrix
that I'm initializing for this
particular grid world task. Then the
second element is the transition matrix.
So please note that I'm using all the
existing Pymdp functionalities to define
a random A matrix and then using an
identity matrix on top of that.
So, yeah, I'm not doing anything new.
Here it is the existing Pymdp
functionality. Then what I can do now is
define the B matrix, which is also
called transition matrix. So the
transition matrix encodes transitions
like where I'm going to end up in the
future if I start from a particular
state and take an action. So that's the
idea where it depends upon the number of
states, which is the hidden state
modality and number of controls. So it
has the structure of state action state
where if I take an action from a
particular state where I'm going to end
up. So that is also a future state,
right. So I'm going to initialize it as
the true environment state. So now this
is part of the environment that I've
built. It will give out the B matrix.
It might be worth it to look at the
structure of this B matrix.
So here we have 25, 25 four. So that
means that if I take an action from a
particular state where I'm going to
enter and we have the true transition
dynamics for this particular grid by
design. So there is a function called
get true B and that will give us the
true b of the system which the agent can
use. Okay? So ideally we would want
the agent to learn this, but for the
purpose of this demo we are assuming
that the agent already knows the
structure. And then comes the
prior preference, which is interesting
here in the sense that it is defined as
how closer you are to the gold state.
So if you are at the gold state, then
clearly that is the most sought out
state. You prefer that the most. And how
do you prefer the neighboring states,
right? So that is dependent upon the
square root of the distance or basically
the distance from that particular gold
state. So you define a grid which
is eight cross eight, the same size as
this particular grid world task. And
then we have a method to
kind of add values which is the
preference you have for every state.
And if you render the particular C
matrix you can see the structure which
is the same where this gold state is
more preferred and the surrounding
states less preferred and so on. So now
we have the C matrix also defined in the
classic PMDP way. And then
I initialize that C matrix as the C
matrix we evaluated in the previous cell
which is small C, this particular C
matrix. Okay? And then lastly,
for the generative model we have capital
D which is your prior overhead and
states. And for that I'm using a uniform
object array. So that means that I don't
have a prior of where I am starting. So
let me run the pending cells.
So here the D matrix is a uniform
distribution over hidden states. I don't
know where I'm going to start the
simulations and so on. So this is the
basic structure of the generative model.
And then we have the agent class which I
want to discuss separately, like the
environment, right? So given these
environment parameters, how would you
expect the agent class to work? So where
is the agent class? Inside this folder
structure? Inside the Pymdp
module folder we have an agent Si PY
which is basically a class again and
similar to the environment class here.
Also we have a step function where this
will take an observation to
the function and also a flag whether or
not to learn the environment, which is
optional. So if you disable it, it won't
learn the generative model. If you
enable it, it will update the parameters
of the generative model. And what
basically it does is it will return an
action which is to be taken at this
point of time and the environment can
basically use that action, right? So in
this file we have the agent class which
I will explain in detail.
So I am basically importing that agent
class in this cell and
then we are going to try and reproduce
this behavioral result from the original
sophisticated inference paper. Okay?
And for that. So what we expect is
that given this prior preference
structure, there are local maximas in
this prior preference structure. So if
you start from this particular point,
if you do not plan deep enough, what you
will end up is in one of these local
maximas where you don't see that there
is a highly preferred observation, say
four steps down the line. So if you are
in this particular state, what you will
see is this local maxima and you will go
and sit there because the neighboring
states are less preferred and this state
which is more preferred is not
accessible because of the wall or the
wall structure. So you have to take a
turn and pass through less preferred
states and you need deep planning in
order to enable the agent to do that.
The agent should be able to kind of
simulate four time steps ahead in time
to see that there is this highly
rewarding observation coming to kind of
do that actions. So that's the point
that we are trying to see in this
particular demo. So for a low planning
depth it will basically get stuck in one
of the local maximas but with sufficient
planning depth it will navigate to the
gold state. So that's what we are trying
to see, right? So we have different
planning horizons and what we are
basically doing is give the agent a
generative model which we right now
defined the A matrix, B matrix, C matrix
B matrix. Then we have the planning
horizon of capital N. So here I am,
iterating over planning depth. So N will
be one, three and four for the loop.
Then we have action precision, which is
often denoted by alpha in active
inference literature. So that determines
which action is to be taken. So a highly
precise action precision means that it
will stick to the action with the lowest
expected free energy. But a lower action
precision is kind of probabilistic where
it will also consider other actions.
Then we have a planning precision which
is part of the planning function we'll
discuss, which is often denoted in the
literature as gamma. Then we also have a
search threshold which is extremely
important for sophisticated inference
because as we saw, sophisticated
inference is a tree search and tree
search is bad in the sense that it can
have a lot of computations. But you have
to define a threshold to kind of ignore
many possibilities to make it work. And
that's the idea that we will also
discuss. So just a preview before we
go to the agent class.
What we are trying to do is in a loop we
are going to call the agent step and
environment step in series. So the agent
will see an observation, it will take an
action, that action will go into the
environment, the environment will give
it back new observations and this loop
continues. And we want to see over time
how this loop evolves into a purposeful
behavior and if the agent at all is
capable for that. So before I reveal the
results, let's discuss the agent class.
So in order to give an action, when an
observation is given, the agent should
have the planning and so on, right? So
here is the agent, the sophisticated
inference agent, where we are
actually using the existing Pymdp agent
for some functionalities. So in Pymdp we
already have really well written
functions for perception and
learning. So the only thing we want to
kind of replace is how the agent is
doing planning and how the agent is
taking decisions over policies, right?
So here we
are using that parent agent class.
So from Pymdp agent we
are importing that agent class which is
sitting next to the Si agent that we are
discussing now. And basically
we are taking in the generative model
structure from the main program for this
class to work which is C and D and all
the precisions and threshold parameter I
mentioned, then it is kind of
normalizing the prior preference that we
mentioned in the main program. So here
if I look at how C is,
the structure of C is defined in terms
of numbers and the prior preference is
often interpreted or it should be a
probabilistic distribution for the
computations to work, right? So we are
going to normalize it as a probabilistic
distribution rather than having
numbers that don't add up to one. So
that's what's happening here. We are
using Softmax to do that. Then what we
are doing is we are initializing the
existing PMDP agent with these
generative model parameters and what we
are intending to do is write a
planning function for a given planning
horizon and a given threshold for trees.
Okay, so there are three functions in
this agent class. One is a helper
function for planning which we will
discuss now. Then there is a planning
function itself which is going to do
planning using tree search. And then
because it is a recursive tree search,
we are going to need an additional
function that implements that recursive
evaluation where we are going to call
this function called forward search
inside the function itself. So we are
calling this function inside this
function. So that is to calculate
expected free energy for the next step
and it will call it again for the next
step till our planning horizon. So
that's the idea of recursive looping and
finally it will return the expected free
energy for all actions given an
observations and then we just implement
the step function where it is written
sequentially what to do given an
observation.
So going back to the demo
here we have this first
idea where you get an observation and
it gives out an action. So let's go to
the agent step function and imagine what
happens. So if it is time t equal to
zero or in the beginning of the
experiment, what it is ideally.
Supposed to do in the first place is
infer that state using its observation.
So what we are giving it is an
observation and using the modules for
inference, it's going to come up with a
belief QS, which is a
belief about states. Okay, so self dot
QS is the belief inside the agent and
once it has a belief about where it is
right now, it can implement plan
research which is do planning for this
particular belief of hidden state right
now. And once it has done planning, it
can take decision using the sample
action function in Pymdp and basically
return that action. And for every other
time steps, the sequence remains the
same. But it is also learning about the
structure if you enable learning in your
agent class. So that's the step
function. But in order to do planning,
what it does is it kind of reorganizes
the generative model structure for any
number of hidden state modalities and
any number of observation modalities.
So to discuss how melting works,
I would like to talk about the new A
matrices and B matrices it evaluates for
implementing that planning and let's
understand that. So let's go back to the
original hidden state factors. So here
we only have one hidden state factor.
So that's why it is B zero, right? And B
one does not exist because we only have
one hidden state factor. But imagine
that if I have two hidden state factors
with the same size maybe. So here it
could be a location and maybe something
else inside the agent's mind.
And we should also have controls for
these two hidden state factors. Just
like so
there should be control for every hidden
state factor if you're familiar with
active inference idea and
then maybe the observation space is also
directly observing these two hidden
state factors. Okay, so this is a new
Generative Model structure with multiple
hidden states and multiple observation
modalities. And right away you can see
that the dimensionalities of your
parameters change. You have 25
observations coming from 25
times 25 hidden states. And if you look
at the structure of the first
observation modality, it's the same.
But what we want is a new matrix where
it's going to be 25 with not
two hidden states but just one hidden
state. It's only a reorganization of the
generative model, but computations
essentially remains the same.
So that's what this helper
function is trying to do, which will
make things easier for us when we have
multiple hidden state modalities. So if
you have multiple hidden state
modalities, we are going to compute how
many total states you have, which is the
multiplication of number of hidden
states in each modality. Okay? So if you
have 25 hidden states in one modality
and 25 hidden states in the other
modality, you're going to have 625 total
number of states. And if you have four
actions each in each modalities, then
you have total of 16 actions which is
nothing but the combination of these
four actions each in the modalities.
So you're going to have four times 416
actions if you have two modalities. And
it's basically going to build a
generative model that has the same model
parameters but just with a different
dimension structure so that it's easier
for us to calculate the expected. So now
we have a new A and new B and
a new belief which is nothing but tensor
products of existing parameters and
beliefs. It's nothing but a new big
matrix and nothing else. Okay?
It's not a change, it's just a
transformation of structure. And given
this A, B and Q, we are going
to predict what's going to happen in the
future and evaluate the expected free
energies for them. So in order to do
planning, so that's the second function.
What we are going to do is first call
the first function which will do the
melting for us and set up the generative
model in good dimensions, easy to
compute. Then we have the expected free
energy itself for all the actions and
then we have the probability that
depends upon this expected free energy
for these actions. So why is it just the
actions and not the observations?
Because here we are going to evaluate
expected free energy of actions for
the given observations, right? So let me
go back to the slides
and discuss this pictorially to
make things easier. So here we have the
grid and we have the prior footprints.
And what we are trying to implement is
that if you observe some observation at
time T, then you're going to consider
the consequences of your actions given
that observation, because you can
predict what's going to happen. Because
in your generative model you have the
transition dynamics that will tell you,
given this state, if I take this action,
where I'm going to end up, right? So
that's basically predicting what's going
to happen in the future and you're right
now considering the consequence of
available actions in your arsenal. And
then if you take an action, then you can
predict what's going to happen in the
next time step as a new observation,
right? So you have a probability
distribution that tells you that say
this observation is the most likely and
the other observations are not really
likely. Then what you will do is you do
this again, you consider the consequence
of doing your actions from that
particular observation and this goes on
in your planning depth, right? So this
can be thought of as maybe you want to
go to the gym. Then you are going to
consider all the consequences. What will
happen if I wear my shoes, if I don't
wear my shoes, if I go in my car, if I
don't go in my car, then you realize
that, okay, I have to wear my shoes.
Then you consider the consequence that
I'm now ready to go to the gym and me
going to the gym will end up me being in
the gym. So that's the idea. You
consider the consequence of where you
are right now and you can go as much as
you want, right. You can predict. So in
a game of chess, you might be in a
particular state. You consider your
consequences, you see the future, you
consider consequences from that future,
and you can go as deep as you want
depending upon your computational
abilities. Right. So that's what you're
trying to implement in this agent class
where we are considering consequences?
Yeah. So for every modality
we are going to consider the expected
free energy for actions. And this
will basically call the next function,
which is forward search. So forward
search is implementing the thing that I
just mentioned, considering
consequences. And in forward search,
what you are basically doing is for
every action. So in line 149,
I have a loop that goes over every
action. Then I'm going to consider the
posterior or the consequences of all
those actions. I use my transition
probabilities to evaluate that
consequences. Then I'm going to predict
the observations, because my prior
preferences are defined in terms of
observations. I'm going to predict my
observations and then evaluate the
expected free energy, which is the sum
of risk and ambiguity.
Okay? I hope that makes sense. Like
here, you have considered the
consequence, which is consequence of
future, which is post or posterior. And
you're basically evaluating how good
that posterior is depending upon your
expected free energy. And that becomes
the expected free energy for that
particular action. And you do this for
all the actions. Okay. And why
this is powerful? It is because you can
go as deep as you want. So here in the
next step, you go to this loop where you
will check if I am crossing my deep
planning or the depth of planning. And
then you are doing basically the same.
Given that posterior, what is the
consequence of the actions of that
particular posterior. So here for
considering that we are again calling
the parent function. So the same
function, forward search, to consider
consequences of those combinations and
it will basically come back and add up
to your expected free energy. So what
happens over this sequence is that you
consider some or all future consequences
and then all that values will trickle
up your tree. And that sum of the
expected free energy will tell you which
action is good or which action is bad,
which you can take to kind of see your
preferred observations. So that's the
idea of implementing tree search. And I
will also talk about the importance of
this threshold here,
which makes this algorithm possible. So
without this threshold, this algorithm
will not work. I will explicitly talk
about why that is the case. And then
once you evaluate the expected free
energy for all available actions, given
the present state, you can basically
compute what you call the action
distribution. That is how probable is my
action or how I should take my action.
And we also have this action precision
parameter alpha. So if alpha is very
high then it basically is a highly
skewed distribution where you will
always choose the action that minimizes
expected free energy. If alpha is really
low then it's going to be a more sparse
or spread out distribution. And then you
can use this action distribution to
sample actions in
the agent environment loop. We just
finished doing planning and computing
that action distribution. Then using
that action distribution, you can sample
an action from your policy space. So
let's look at the policy space in this
generative model.
So I'm switching back to the original
generative model with one hidden state
factor and let's
do planning and maybe
initialize this agent.
I just want to initialize this agent to
see the policy space, not run the loop.
So I
initialize this agent, say for planning
depth of one. And if I look at agent
policies, I can see that I have
basically four available actions which
is north, south, east and west. And if I
have an action distribution, it will
tell me how probable is to take that
action. So if I look at agent UPI,
okay, so this is not defined because I
have not done planning, but I can do
planning and then it will be defined.
Yeah, so I implemented planning with
research and then now I have an action
distribution. So for this particular
scenario, I am going to take my third
action the most which is zero point 99.
Basically that's the probability which
is north, south and east in this
particular case. I just wanted to kind
of familiarize you with the matrices,
but we are now going to see the
agent environment loop in action.
Now you can sample an action from the
sample action function and then
implement learning which is using the
standard Pymdp way where I will update
my transition dynamics and likelihood
dynamics depending upon what I see and
what's my belief and so on. So my
emphasis is on the decision making part.
So once you sample an action, then that
action basically goes back to the
environment. Okay, so now let us
implement this for a planning depth of
one and see how the agent behaves.
So here if it is a planning depth of
one, then that means that the agent is
only considering the consequence of one
time step ahead, just seeing the
immediate future for doing planning,
right? So I'm giving the planning depth
of one. I'm resetting the environment
where the agent is going to start from
that initial start state,
and in the loop, it's going to get
that observation, take that action,
give back an action, and we will look at
the action probabilities. And also we
will give that action back to the
environment, get back the observation,
and this loop continues till the episode
is terminated. And I have set the
episode length to be eight, just to see
the outcome of eight action. So when
we run this loop, these matrices are
nothing but the action distributions of
how likely each action is to be taken.
And this is where the agent end up in
the last time step. Okay? So let's maybe
kind of also enable this environment
render that will show us where the agent
is at every time step. So initially the
agent was at this location and we have
an action distribution of this here. So
north, south, east and west. So the
agent knows that it should go north.
Why? Because if I look at the prior
preference, this state is more
preferred than this state. Right? So the
agent successfully calculated the
expected free energy and inferred that,
okay, I should go to this state and not
stay in this state. And because it has
the generative model of transitions
available, it can infer that I should
take an action north to go to this
state. So that's good. And the agent
goes to north. And at this particular
state, the agent infers that it should
go to north southeast. So it will take
an action east and it will go here.
And at this point of time, I want your
attention where the action distribution
is equally probable for north and east.
Why is that? Because the agent is only
looking at the immediate future. Right.
So let's go back to the prior preference
where the agent is right now here,
or is it here? Yeah, it is right now
here in this particular state. And if
the agent is considering immediate
consequences of just one action, then
these two states are equally good for it
to be in the next state. So there is no
distinction between these two states if
it is only looking at the immediate
future. So that means that the expected
free energygies will conclude that I
should go to north or east. It doesn't
matter if I'm looking at just one time
step ahead. Okay? That's the idea.
And out of probability it is going
here. It took the action east and
from this state, when it's doing
inference, it's inferring that this
state is better and basically it's
ending up in this local maxima state,
which is this particular state where the
neighboring states are less preferred.
And this is Wall and you can't go there
because it is forbidden for the agent by
structure. So it's basically going to
sit there forever where it only sees
that local maximum of prior preference.
And let's look at what might
happen if you have higher planning
depth. So if I go to the planning depth
of three, then that means that
the agent is actually reaching the goal
state at the last time step. But still
in the third time point, it had two
probabilistic actions, north and east.
So here from this particular state, out
of probability, it took the action north
but it can all equally take the action
east and end up in this local maxima.
So let's run again and probably it will
end up in this local maxima, okay?
And only for the planning depth of four,
which is sufficient enough, which is
necessary for this particular grid,
the agent is fully sure of what to do.
So at every time point it is fully sure
of what to do, that it has to go north,
then east, north, north, north, east,
east and south and reach this particular
goal state. So only for time step or
planning depth n equal to four, it can
successfully navigate this grid with
100% certainty. So that's the idea.
That's the implementation that I hope
you got. So there is also this idea of
action precision. So here it's a high
action precision. That is why it is
taking the actions. That is from the
probability. If it is a low action
precision like one, then the
good actions are more probable. But that
doesn't mean that it will be taken right
here by luck, it is taking the right
actions and reaching the state. But here
probabilities are most passed. But you
will also see like exploration behavior
in more number of trials if you control
this action precision. So I set it to a
high value to make sure that the agent
reaches the goal for this particular
problem. But it's worth playing and it's
important, right? Okay,
yeah. So for different planning depths
like one, three and four in this
problem, this is the behavior that you
expect. For lower planning depths,
which is not sufficient, the agent ends
up in local maximas or
local minimas of expected free energy or
local maximas of prior preference. But
with sufficient planning depth, it's
able to navigate and reach the goal. So
that brings us to the last point in this
tutorial where why is it
important to have a threshold in
evaluating sophisticated inference? So
by threshold, what we mean is that we
can ignore future possibilities in two
levels, right? You can ignore not likely
actions or not likely observations in
this research. But if you consider the
consequences of all actions and
observations, that means that you'll
have to consider four consequences in
the first place. Then you will have to
consider four times the action states in
the next time step for the next time
step. Then all of that multiplied with
the number of actions and this tree
search becomes intractable and you'll
explode. And it's even worse than the
classical active inference policy space
problem. But by defining a threshold of
even a small value, we'll ignore
possibilities. So where is that
implemented? In the forward search
algorithm, we are considering actions
with only action probabilities greater
than the particular threshold. Here I am
defining it as one by 16. Also in the
parent paper, it's one by 16 the
action probability. Okay?
So if it is zero, then that means that
it will consider all the consequences of
future and that's intractable. So you
can ignore actions which is not
probable, and also ignore states which
is less likely, or only consider states
that has probability greater than this
particular threshold value, and that
significantly reduces the computational
complexity, where you will only consider
combinations that are probable in the
future. Tree and that lets you go deeper
in your planning horizon.
That's an important point here. And if
you compare the time that takes
for deeper planning for a search
threshold of zero, so a
search threshold of zero means that you
will consider all consequences. And the
more deep you plan, the more time
it takes. And if you see to consider
only the first future or the immediate
future, it takes 0.1 second. For
considering three possibilities into the
future, it takes 3 seconds, and for four
it takes 300 seconds. And you can see
that the computational time is
exponentially growing. But if you have a
very small search threshold,
you have that computational time that
makes sense for implementation in real
world, right? So here for N equal to
four, that is four times steps into the
future, it's only taking 0.1 second.
And that's okay. I can still do
simulations with this complexity, but
there is no way I can talk about how
less the computational complexity is.
It truly depends on the nature of your
prior preferences and environment in
action. But this search threshold
actually works in real life, and we just
saw that in our simulations, right? For
N equal to four, it took only like 0.3
seconds in our simulations. But if you
set the search threshold as zero,
it already is 300 seconds for doing full
depth planning. And if I set a planning
depth of five, then it will basically
run forever maybe, and I will not be
able to do simulation. So that's the
idea of search threshold.
So actually, that's it. I wanted to
explain the Agent class,
the environment class, and the
particular demo and yeah, maybe it's a
good time for questions if anybody was
listening. And I hope people get
to play with this code and look
at the tutorial and implement this and
build generative models like this. So
this particular example is how do you
build a generative model for this grid
world task and see how the Agent is able
to take meaningful actions? But here we
gave it that true structure of the
environment in the B matrix and A matrix
and so on. But you can also play around
with learning in
the sense that while defining the
Agent step, you can add a flag that
says learning equal to true.
And if you start with an uninformed AB
and so on, you can experiment on how the
Agent is learning that environment.
Here you can look at the B matrix in the
beginning, you can look at the B matrix
after, say, ten trials and see how the
learning is taking place here. It
doesn't matter because the agent knows
the structure and it won't learn much.
But if it starts from an unknown
structure, then there is scope of
learning also to be implemented. And
it's already implemented because we
are using existing Pymdp functionalities
for learning A and B and it's already
part of the step function. So I hope
step function is clear, which is the
only thing you need to know if you're
trying to implement sophisticated
inference and just the names of these
matrices if you want to probe them and
look at them. And yeah, I hope the
session was useful. So I thank my
collaborators and Connor, who maintains
Pimdp, and also Brendan who runs the
Pimdp Fellowship, which I was part of,
and that's where I worked on
implementing sophisticated inference in
Pimdp and it will be part of the
original Pymdp module soon. And I hope
people can start using this module to
simulate sophisticated inference
experiments and this basically becomes
useful. So maybe it's a good time to
discuss questions or clarifications on
the code or maybe it's a good time to
take a break, as Daniel was.
Thank you. That was awesome. Well,
I have a few different questions and
I'll read a few from the live chat.
So I'll first just go to the live chat
and then ask those and then ask some
other questions. So Dave asks, how do
you think about the neural
implementation of recursion? Brains
don't seem to implement computer
hardware style recursion deeper than a
stack depth of one. Aside from heavily
over learned tasks, we can confine
ourselves to asking about recursion for
the purposes of exploring temporally
deep state spaces, searching forward in
time. So how do we reconcile this
really beautiful and elegant and
computationally efficient full depth
tree search with the biological basis of
multiscale planning? Yeah,
so I'm not an expert in neural
computation, but the answer to that
would be basically you're doing only
one computation at a time, right?
And all you need is some
memory to store your beliefs and use
those beliefs to kind of do the same
computation again. So we are not talking
about this hardcore
recursive implementation. We are only
doing local computations at a time. And
just because of the structure of the
generative model and because we have
memory, this can be done. And I don't
see why brain can't do it, even though
individual neurons might not be able to
do it. The brain has memory. The brain
has the ability to store memory and the
ability to dream, the ability to
simulate. It knows the consequences of
actions. And you do this on a daily
basis where you plan your future
and decide what to do. Right? So on a
single neuron level, I'm not really sure
of how to answer that question, but I
don't really see why the brain can't do
it as an organism.
Cool. Okay, to the code.
I guess I have a few questions. Can we
go back to the maze?
And of course, if anyone else has
questions in the live chat, just go for
it. So in
the maze, how does the
moves that are possible, how is that
reflected? What stage is it updated,
for example, that it initially knows
that it can only go up and then it can
only go right or down? Where is that
reflected with the updating of kind
of that relational aspect of
affordances? What is even possible to
do? And then how does it evaluate in a
deep tree search?
Does it need to know what things
could or couldn't happen in the future?
So, if I understand the questions
correctly, there is an important
distinction between the generative
process and the generative model,
right? So in the grid world, which is
the generative process, we have
implemented all of that manually, where
we have this transition dynamics that
already knows what will happen if you
take an action from a state. So it's
like an environment that knows how to
work. So it's like a reality where there
are consequences of actions and it's
already there. But this information is
available to the agent to be part of its
generative model. And in the generative
model, what it basically does is use
that transition dynamics, which is given
or learned to simulate what might happen
in the future. Okay? So once I have that
transition dynamics, if I go to the
where's the if I go to the tree
search, what it is essentially doing is
evaluating the posterior given a
particular state and an action J. So
from my generative model, I know that if
I start from this state and if I take
this action, I go to this posterior and
I consider all the consequences. And if
in the generative model, it is unlikely
that if I go east, I don't go there and
so on, it's automatically reflected
in the expected free energy.
So I hope that answers the question. So
here, if I set the action
precision to be high and also
enable the so
initially I am in this particular state,
and with respect to the expected free
energy, what I'm doing is I'm using my
generative model to predict what will
happen if I take four actions. And my
predictions will say that if I take
North, I will go here. And if I take all
the other actions, I'll stay here. And
because in my prior preference, north is
more preferred, I can infer that north
is the action I should go for.
So that's the idea. So here, the grid
structure is given to the agent. And it
might be a little confusing, but the
agent can also learn this grid structure
and this will work. So once I know the
grid structure as an agent, I can
simulate the future and consider the
consequences of action, right? So that's
what's happening. And once I am in this
state, I will consider the consequence
of all four actions, and I will infer
that, okay, going east is better because
that will take me to this state. So
there is always a difference between or
you should keep in mind how generative
model and generative process are two
different things, and what the agent
knows might not be the reality or might
be the reality, depending upon what you
give it. Makes sense.
Cool. So if you were going to go
about making a new situation
that you wanted to do generative
modeling for, do you tend to start from
an existing working Pi MDP notebook and
start modifying state spaces, or do you
draw it out on a canvas? How would you
recommend somebody other than
replicating what is shown here? Let's
just say we're interested in something
that's not exactly just a maze. What do
we do to get our head
around how we should proceed?
Yeah, good question. So if you
are trying to simulate, say, a new
environment, you have the heavy lifting
to do, which is to define the generative
model for the agent. You can either
define a very sparse generative model,
which the agent can learn, but you have
to define the structure. That structure
should be there, and only using that
structure, the agent can learn the
generative model. So here you can make
use of this cell of code to understand
how I define the structure of the grid.
Okay, so I am defining a structure for
the agent for it to make use of. I'm
saying that there are 25 valid states
and there are four available actions.
And this is the standard way of defining
the state space in Pymdp. And you also
have to define the central
parameters ABC and D for the agent
simulations. So here I am defining A
using my state space and observation
space. But this step of giving it
or telling it that it's an identity
matrix is my decision choice in my
modeling. I don't have to do this for
simulations. I can see if the agent is
learning it from a random A matrix or
when it starts from a random A matrix.
And similarly for this B matrix, this
structure is defined. And there are
functions like this which can give you a
random B matrix. But this is a modeling
choice where if I want to give it the
grid structure or not give it the grid
structure, I can start from a random B
matrix, let the agent learn, and look at
that learned B metric. Just for the
purpose of the demo. I gave it the grid
structure to enable it to take the
actions. But it's not a mandatory thing.
So this notebook is useful in the sense
that you know what to do, but definitely
you should play around with steps that
may not be mandatory. Right, so if I
give a prior preference for this state
to be the maximum, then you can see
behavior that. The agent will try and go
there. Right. So this prior preference
is defined in conjunction that this is
the goal state, but this may not be the
goal state. And in a different ask,
what prior preference means is different
according to the environment. Right.
So that's also there and your prior. So
once you define that generative model,
which you have to do, you can't run from
it, then everything is kind of
automated. The agent only
have to use the agent step,
give it the observation from the
environment. The agent knows how to take
actions, and then everything that
happens inside the agent, you don't
really have to worry.
So this structure, I'm sure, will be
useful for your particular task that you
are trying to model in your hmm.
Yes, very interesting. And how would you
contrast that or point to any
similarities or differences with how
this would be pursued outside of active
inference? Like if somebody were just
going to use another kind of deep policy
agent in the maze example, what parts of
the process would be familiar and what
parts would be like a lot of work that
wasn't expected or skipping through
parts that were a lot of work otherwise.
Yeah. So the
general structure is very familiar to
somebody who does things like this in
reinforcement learning. So the idea that
it's an agent step and environment step,
so this is the standard OpenAI gym
way of writing an environment and a
standard OpenAI way of writing an agent.
Okay? So if you have a Q learning agent
who does the same trying to navigate,
then the way you have to define the
queue matrix is the heavy lifting there.
It's just a state action mapping. And in
contrast to that, in active inference,
you have to come up with a generative
model that you want to see. So in active
inference, generative model is the
central thing. Right. Without a
generative model, there is no meaning of
purposeful behavior in active inference.
So the only unfamiliar part for a
person who is coming from, say, a field
like reinforcement learning is the
structure of the generating model. But
there is no way, other than getting used
to it, where it's the palm DP structure
which dominates. But if you're doing
deep active inference, all of this is
going to be neural networks and palm DPS
are also not active inference things.
Right. It's an industrial engineering
thing. So palm DPS must also be familiar
for people who are coming from the
computer science background, just the
idea that what really happens in the
agent is the active inference part where
we have expected free energy s and
variation of free energy energies. And
if you want to learn about that, then
you have to go to the agents and see how
it works. Look at the matrices
numerically, see what's happening. But
in a level where you want to get
started, I don't see any problem. All of
this is standard frameworks
like palmdps and OpenAI gym
environments, agent environment loop.
All this is very deeply discussed in
computer science. It's not cool.
So what other motifs
or cognitive phenomena are you excited
or how do you see the Pi MDP development
trajectory continuing after your
sophisticated inference gets pulled in?
Yeah, so the Pimdp
had the original functionality and the
functionality to implement or simulate
general active inference agents with the
policy space and so on. And that enabled
a lot of people in the community who
are not familiar with complicated
coding and so on, who people who do
psychology, psychiatry, and all the
things. Right. So whoever want to come
up and try implement active inference,
pymdp enabled that. And I am hoping that
this module will enable people who want
to try out sophisticated inference
experiments in their particular domain.
So if you spend some time and get
familiarized yourself with the structure
of how Pymdp works, then everything else
is just writing a jupyter notebook with
minimal code, right, to simulate this.
So if you have a particular task in your
domain, I don't see a problem for a
beginner to kind of try and code it.
And what I'm very excited to see is
people using this module for variety of
experiments, just like how people
started using Pymdp and sophisticated
inference is taking off. And it's now
widely talked about how
it is the way of doing active inference.
And I'm really hoping that people in
various domains start using this module
and see their experiments, and I look
forward for the feedback. Yeah, so what
Pimdp did two years ago, I'm hoping this
module will do to people who are trying
to model active inference in the soap
state. So you mentioned the OpenAI
gym and the standardized format, and
what benchmarks do you use or
what kind of test suites are you
comparing, and how do we really know
when we've made a generative model that
really exceeds or excels in a way that
other techniques are just
not doing? Yeah, so if I may
go to the OpenAI gym website,
we have several experiments. There the
classical reinforcement learning
examples like the lunar lander that you
see in this screen right now. So active
inference from its inception has faced
problems of scaling to tasks. And that's
in itself a field of research in active
inference, scaling active inference.
And that's one of the reasons why deep
active inference took over dealing with
tasks like this. So there are benchmarks
even now where the sophisticated
inference may not be able to deal with
state spaces. And personally, that's my
research. In my PhD. I am actually
looking at optimizing computations
in sophisticated inference algorithms
that lets you scale up to environments
like that. But to get started, you will
have to kind of write code and see if it
works for an environment, then look at
if it's not working, then you have to
look at methods to scale it up and so
on. So if I am talking about benchmarks,
sophisticated inference is as good as
any RL algorithms for this state space.
So for small problems, sophisticated
inference will work and it's really
good. But for high dimensional problems
like this, the classical implementation
that I just showed might not work, but
it's good enough for any decent
experiment. But if you want to scale up,
then that's still open and it's a new
field of research and what you do might
become a next new important paper.
So that's all I can tell in that regard.
Cool. You have to work and see what.
Measures do you think you'd be looking
for, like computational
resources or what are the measures that
even make sense to juxtapose such
different methods? Yeah, so the
OpenAI Gym was designed for that,
to compare different algorithms.
So OpenAI Gym by definition is a
collection of many environments. So in
my demo, I was talking about the grid
environment. Openiigm is nothing but a
collection of many environments which
will let you interact with those
environments using the environment step
function. Yeah.
So here we have the environment step
function that will let you interact with
the lunar lander. And that particular
task will have matrixes that lets you
judge how good or bad your algorithm is.
So in this lunar lander problem, how
optimally can you land your rover
between these two flags by spending
minimizing the fuel and so on. So those
matrices are very tasks specific, and
that's one direction you have to take.
You can take try and compete with RL
algorithms in matrixes, but the right
potential or the potential I see in
sophisticated inference is modeling
intelligent behavior, where in RL the
focus is to get things done to make this
work. But it's not really explainable,
especially deep RL and deep learning
methods. But in active inference, if you
manage to scale it up, they are
explainable and that will
let you understand how intelligence
emerges with time. And I see that more
interesting than competing with RL,
because if your focus is getting things
done, then maybe engineering is the
right way and not active inference.
Awesome. Any other comments or thoughts?
Aswin, do you have any other comments or
thoughts? No, I'm pretty happy.
I hope I was clear explaining the code.
Maybe it was too complicated or simple,
depending upon your level, but I hope it
is useful to at least one person who
would start using this and write the
code. Thank you so much for your time.
Awesome. And thank you for the
opportunity. Thank you for joining.
Till next time. See you. Thank you so
much.